small businesses are slowly coming back
from months of closures
so many were hit hard by covid
restrictions here locally
bianca holman shares how one small
business owner is recovering
small businesses are regrouping from
months of closures
laying off employees declining sales
these are problems all too familiar for
boutique owner angela renee who
specializes in fashions for curvy women
it was devastating it
really really was so we um you know now
we're you know we've been able to
regroup but it was it was definitely a
struggle during a recent mondays with
monica interview
renee learned about money for
entrepreneurs you can get an sba loan
for working capital to
acquire or expand a business and they'll
make your payments for the first three
months
until the end of september when or until
the funds run out
and also they're waiving their
traditional fee which can be as high as
2.7 percent
2.75 of the loan amount information from
the small
business corporation can help owners
make smart decisions
i think the important thing is to this
network is
to connect with your local chambers to
hear about things and resources that are
made
available to you and to be out there
networking and talking
and learning invest in yourself by
learning
there's a lot of information available
online and through non-profit resources
right before pandemic restrictions renee
moved into a new location in fashion
show mall near louis vuitton and neiman
marcus
as las vegas reopens she looks forward
to more foot traffic
renee plans to take advantage of the
small business funding
saying it will give her peace of mind
preventing her boutique from failure
this type of funny would give me that
security that i can have
that nest egg for my business so i
so any unexpected challenges that come
up i'd be able to
you know secure my business know that
i'm stable kirkland says if you don't
know what you qualify for
reach out to your local chamber of
commerce bianca holman
8 news now